[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen alles
Wichtige vom Sport erfahren Sie von
Norbert Lehmann ein schönen guten Abend
in der Türkei geht das Rennen um die
Präsidentschaft in die zweite Runde
Entscheidungen der Stichwahl der
türkische Präsident Erdogan verpasst die
absolute Mehrheit Herausforderer
[Musik]
Präsident selensky Kampfdrohnen und
Flugabwehrraketen zu
dritte Spiel dritte Niederlage bei der
Eishockey WM verliert Deutschland auch
gegen die USA
es war spannend bei der Wahl gestern in
der Türkei und es bleibt spannend denn
wer Präsident wird entscheidet sich
jetzt erst in zwei Wochen am 28 Mai
geht's in eine Stichwahl denn
Amtsinhaber Erdogan verfehlt die
absolute Mehrheit denkbar knapp er kommt
auf
49,51% sein Herausforderer auf
44,88%
Königsmacher mit seiner Wahlempfehlung
für die Stichwahl könnte also der
ultra-nationalist Sinan ohan sein ihn
haben 5,17% gewählt Anna
wir kämpfen bis zum bitteren Ende
twittert Erdogans Kontrahent dann ein
Online-Appell ich bin hier ich bin hier
ihr seid auch hier ich werde bis zum
Ende kämpfen ich bin hier
gibt sich Kampfes lustig wohl wissen
dass die nächsten zwei Wochen die
härtesten seiner politischen Karriere
werden könnten Rückblick noch in der
Nacht schrumpfen die Prognosen für
Erdogan von fast 60 auf 49% sein
Herausforderer pendelt sich bei knapp
45% ein Erdogan interpretiert das so
die Tatsache dass die Wahlergebnisse
noch nicht endgültig verstehen ändert
nichts daran dass die Wahl unserer
Nation eindeutig zu unseren Gunsten
ausgefallen ist
an diesem Nachmittag dann steht fest es
wird eine Stichwahl geben und mit ihr
kommt ein dritter ins Spiel Sinan oan
der dritte Präsidentschaftskandidat
Vorsitzender eines
ultra-nationalistischen Bündnis mit gut
5% der Stimmen hinter sich im
ZDF-Interview gefällt er sich in der
neuen Rolle
in den Stichwahlen könnten wir die
entscheidenden Stimmen liefern
vielleicht sind wir sogar der
Königsmacher deshalb sind wir mit diesem
Ergebnis zufrieden
nur eine Bedingung habe er an die die
seine stimmen wollen keine gemeinsame
Sache mit der prokurdischen HDP ich will
das Abstand zu Terroristen gehalten wird
die HDP kriegt das nicht hin eine
Zwickmühle für College denn auch die
Stimmen der Kurden wird er brauchen wenn
er in zwei Wochen erneut im Rennen zum
präsidentenantritt doch unabhängig
welche Wählergruppe er nun um werben
wird der Schlachtruf auf Twitter richtet
sich an alle
der brasen Ankara woran liegt es denn
dass der Kandidat Opposition schlechter
abgeschnitten hat als gedacht
also was ganz klar es ist dass die
Opposition im Wahlkampf benachteiligt
waren 90% der Medien stehen unter
Kontrolle der Regierung da konnte die
Opposition ihre Botschaft nicht
drüberbringen und dann ist das Thema
offenbar nicht genommen nicht gelungen
der religiös konservativen und
nationalistischen Wählern die in der
Türkei offenbar dann doch die Mehrheit
stellen die Ängste zu nehmen
Ängste die die Regierung vorher geschürt
hatte indem sie zum Beispiel überhaupt
paktiere mit Terroristen das hat viele
wohl verunsichert und dann haben sie am
Ende dann doch bei dem starken Mann von
dem sie glauben dass er die Probleme der
Türkei am besten lösen könnte weil ähm
Erdogan ihr Kreuz gemacht und jetzt
gibt's in zwei Wochen eine Stichwahl hat
den Herausforderer noch eine
realistische Chance er dann zu besiegen
[Musik]
also ich glaube das ist einfacher ist
für die Regierung Seite ihre
Unterstützer in zwei Wochen nochmal zu
mobilisieren ich glaube dass das der
Opposition schwerer fallen könnte viele
mit denen wir heute gesprochen haben
waren doch wirklich sehr frustriert und
enttäuscht und so könnten viele zu Hause
bleiben weil sie glauben dass sie eh
nicht gewinnen können und dann ist auch
mein Gefühl dass die Unterstützer von
Sinan Ohren politisch doch eher dem
Erdogan Lagern nahe stehen und den zwei
Wochen dann auch für Erdogan stimmen
können danke für diese Einschätzung
in Deutschland hat Präsident Erdogan bei
den Wahlberechtigten Deutsch Türkinnen
und Türken offenbar noch besser
abgeschnitten als in der Türkei knapp
zwei Drittel hätten hier für den
amtszenhaber gestimmt so Zahlen der
staatlichen Nachrichtenagentur einer
Dolo dort die Farbe hat sich in der
türkischen Community in Duisburg
umgehört
Erdogan Anhänger jubeln gestern Abend in
Duisburg da ist Erdogans Vorsprung noch
groß später schrumpft dieser Vorsprung
bis fest steht dass es eine Stichwahl
geben wird
dennoch zeigen sich heute hier die
meisten weiter von Erdogan Sieg
überzeugt also die Beste für unsere
Heimat oder was soll ich sagen die beste
Freundin kommt wir hoffen die
Anhänger sind in der Minderheit nur ein
gutes Drittel der Wahlberechtigten
Türken in Deutschland stimmten für ihn
65 Prozent für Erdogan da muss man sich
auch klar machen dass auch in
Deutschland gewisser Weise ein unfairer
Wahlkampf stattfindet das heißt die
Ressourcen die Mittel die über die
türkischen Konsulate aber auch durch die
dicke Moscheen und viele viele andere
Stellen mobilisiert werden können werden
eingesetzt zugunsten Erdogans und seine
AKP die Stimmen der Deutsch Türken bei
der Stichwahl sind wichtig sie könnten
sogar Wahl entscheidend sein
also noch mal zwei Wochen Wahlkampf der
Kontrahenten auch bei uns in unserem
Online-Angebot lesen Sie was ein
Wahlsieg des einen oder anderen für die
Türkei bedeuten würde
zur deutschen Innenpolitik und zur Frage
wie die Ampelkoalition in Berlin die
Bremen bei beurteilt schließlich haben
die Grünen herbe Verluste erlitten nach
der neuesten amtlichen Hochrechnung
liegt die SPD von Bürgermeister
bogenschulte auf 30,1% zu die CDU
verliert und kommt auf 25 %. die Grünen
verlieren stark stehen bei 12 die Linke
fast stabil bei
11,1%. die rechtspopulistischen BÜRGER
IN WUT liegen zu auf
9,5%, die FDP kommt auf 5,2% Andrea
Mauer
am Tag nach der Bremen Wahl tritt die
grüne Spitzenkandidatin Maike Schäfer
zurück nicht ohne mit dem Finger auch
nach Berlin zu zeigen es ist auch
eindeutig so dass es keinen Rückenwind
sondern eher starken Gegenwind auf
Bundesebene für die Grünen gab ich will
nur das Thema Wärmepumpe einmal erwähnen
auch die Debatte um
personalverflechtungen im Habeck
Ministerium waren wohl keine
Wahlkampfhilfe der grüne Parteichef
sieht trotzdem keinen Zusammenhang das
nicht gute Wahlergebnis in Bremen jetzt
mit dem mit dem bundesgrün zu tun hätte
das stellt sich jetzt auch nach einem
Tag Reflexion und Anschauung nicht
bessere Stimmung beim Koalitionspartner
es ist das zweitschlechteste Ergebnis
der SPD in Bremen und trotzdem der
Wahlsieg die Parteispitze erklärt dem
parteikurs zum Erfolg wir müssen
ambitionierten Klimaschutz auf den Weg
bringen aber das bedeutet für uns
Sozialdemokratinnen und Sozialdemokraten
immer Klimaschutz und soziale
Gerechtigkeit zusammenzubringen das ist
nicht voneinander trennbar das ist
übrigens auch der Weg den die SPD im
Bremer Land jetzt im Wahlkampf
verkörpert hat Bremens neuer alter
Bürgermeister boven Schulte hat zwei
Koalitionsoptionen weiter regieren mit
Rot-Rot-Grün oder schwarz rot die Linke
hofft aufs weiter mit regieren sie hat
in Bremen fast so viele Stimmen wie die
Grünen geholt ein seltener Erfolg für
die im Bund angeschlagene Partei nur
knapp wieder in der Bremer Bürgerschaft
die FDP Auswirkungen auf die
Bundespolitik sieht Partei Chefin nicht
die Union erklärt die Grünen zu den Wahl
Verlierern und wirkt offensiv für eine
zweier Konstellation und gerade deshalb
möchte ich auch an die SP D appellieren
jetzt auch die Chance wahrzunehmen mit
der CDU in Bremen Gespräche zu führen
das gute Abschneiden der
rechtspopulistischen BÜRGER IN WUT wird
im politischen Berlin als Warnsignal
gesehen genauso die niedrige
Wahlbeteiligung 57,4%
und den größten Dämpfer haben also die
Grünen bei der Wahl in Bremen verpasst
bekommen
ja das heißt das nach der FDP die ja
schon einige Wahl Niederlagen hinter
sich hat und die das dann auch in
Diskussionen über ihre eigene Politik
wieder gespiegelt hatten und auch bei
den Grünen der Druck steigt nicht nur zu
regieren im Bund sondern sich auch zu
profilieren die Parteispitze hat ja
schon darauf aufmerksam gemacht dass die
landespolitische Gründe sieht aber
tatsächlich kann man hier die
bundesstimmung nicht ganz ausklammern es
ist auch hier in Berlin klar dass dass
die erste Wahl war nach der großen
Kritik an der wärmewende und an dem
geplanten Heizungstausch und das wird
hier sehr wohl wahrgenommen und man wird
darüber diskutieren wie können die
Grünen in der Ampel ihre Politik
erkennbar machen ohne dabei gleich zum
wo man zu werden für möglicherweise auch
unbequeme Entscheidungen und was
allerdings nicht zu erwarten ist es eine
komplette konfrontationslinie auf der
sind die Grünen bisher in der Ampel
nicht gewesen sie haben immer sehr
darauf Wert gelegt als staatstragende
Partei wahrgenommen zu werden deswegen
wäre eine komplette Wende und eine
Angriffslinie gegenüber den Ampel
Partnern ein zu krass ein zu krasse
Veränderung das ist erst einmal nicht zu
erwarten vielen Dank für das einordnen
nach der Absage des Bahnstreiks wollen
die Eisenbahner Gewerkschaft EVG und die
Bahn zügig weiter verhandeln am Mittwoch
soll es im kleinen Kreise Vorgespräche
geben sie dienen der Vorbereitung der
nächsten offiziellen Tarifrunde den
einer Woche beginnen soll der
Bahnverkehr lief fast reibungslos wieder
an bis auf einzelne Ausfälle bestreicht
werden aber weiterhin Privatbahnen
jetzt ist es endgültig der frühere
Bundeskanzler Gerhard Schröder darf
Mitglied der SPD bleiben trotz seiner
engen Verbindung zu Russland die Bundes-
der ukrainische Präsident selenski setzt
den Europareise fort und ist heute in
Großbritannien eingetroffen dort
versprach ihm premierst du nach weitere
Waffenlieferungen wie Drohnen mit
größerer Reichweite vor allem die Stadt
bachmut ist in der Ukraine weiter heftig
umkämpft es gibt viele Opfer Christoph
raus aus der Kampfzone weg von
artilleriehagel und Dauerbeschuss raus
aus bachmut ein normaler Bus umgebaut
zur fahrenden Ambulanz bringt verletzt
den sichere Hinterland mag sein dass
manche von ihnen entmutigt sind doch die
freiwillige Helferin Tatjana meint noch
höre sie nur das Gegenteil
alle sind so entschlossen und sagen ich
kann nicht warten bis ich geheilt bin
und weiter für mein Land kämpfen kann
der britische Land sitzt checkers bei
London dort verspricht premiersunak der
Ukraine für ihren Kampf hunderte Drohnen
mit großer Reichweite lässt sogar über
Kampfjets mit sich reden ohne konkreten
Plan wohlgemerkt davor gebe es noch viel
zu tun
es geht nicht nur um die Bereitstellung
von Flugzeugen sondern auch um die
Ausbildung der Piloten und die damit
verbundene Logistik echte Partner sein
sie unterstreicht der ukrainische Gast
und drängt auch hier aufs Tempo we want
to Creed wir wollen diese jet-koalition
gründen und ich stehe dem sehr positiv
gegenüber
Russland der Angreifer veröffentlicht
derweil routiniert neue hochglanz-bilder
seines kam fürs und zeigt sich auch
sonst wenig beeindruckt allenfalls
verärgert vom britischen Engagement
die neuen Waffen werden keinen Einfluss
auf den Verlauf unserer spezialoperation
haben nur mehr Zerstörung bringen und
für die Ukraine wird alles noch
komplizierter
doch die Ukraine sind längst geübt im
Umgang mit kompliziert und gefährlich
hier etwa in einer Metrostation im schon
so oft beschossenen ratgriff die
professionellen Boxer des Landes müssen
in Sicherheit trainieren können warum
nicht mit einem Schaukampf unter der
Erde zwischen den Gleisen
wollen
unten sportlicher Kampf oben Krieg es
ist ein absurder Alltag der wohl noch
lange so weitergehen wird
in Deutschland greifen ja seit Januar
die energiepreisbremsen jetzt untersucht
das Bundeskartellamt ob Versorger zu
hohe Endkundenpreise angesetzt haben um
möglichst hohe Ausgleichszahlungen vom
Staat zu bekommen
konkret geht es um eine zweistellige
Anzahl von Gasversorgern man wolle jetzt
Licht ins Dunkel bringen heißt es
Außenministerin bärburg ist auf Besuch
in Saudi-Arabien aufgrund einer
technischen Flugzeug landete sie mit
zwei Stunden Verspätung in der
Hafenstadt schida dort wurde sie von
ihrem Kollegen Außenminister feisalbin
verhahn empfangen im Mittelpunkt der
Gespräche sollen die Krisen im Sudan und
im Jemen stehen bärburg will aber auch
das Thema Menschenrechte ansprechen
Schlappe für Thailands Militärmachthaber
die demokratische Opposition hat die
Parlamentswahl klar für sich entschieden
nach Auszählung fast aller Stimmen liegt
die Partei nur Vorwort knapp vor der pur
thaiparty die ebenfalls zur Opposition
angehört der Wahlsieger peter röhnrad
hat nicht automatisch das Recht eine
neue Regierung zu bilden der künftige
Regierungschef wird im Juli von den 500
Mitgliedern des Repräsentantenhauses und
dem 250 köpfigen Senat gewählt diese
Naturen werden nicht gewählt sondern vom
Militär ernannt das Verfahren gilt
deshalb als undemokratisch
Kanada leidet seit rund zwei Wochen
unter Waldbränden und die Temperaturen
steigen auf rund 30 Grad die Aussichten
auf Regen gering besonders betroffen die
Provinz Alberta im Westen des Landes
hier sind noch fast 90 Feuer aktiv mehr
als 20 Waldbrände gelten als außer
Kontrolle Johannes
mit Macht fressen sich die Flammen seit
gut zwei Wochen Tag und Nacht durch die
endlosen Wälder von Alberta eine solche
Feuersbrunst hat man hier noch nicht
erlebt mehr als 5.300 Quadratkilometer
Wald sind seit Beginn des Jahres in
Flammen zum Opfer gefallen und jetzt im
Frühling mehr als in den vergangenen
fünf Jahren zusammen
das sind die meisten und größten Folgen
die wir hier jemals in unserem Bezirk
gesehen haben jemals
im Minutentakt nehmen die Löschflugzeuge
Wasser auf und werfen es über den
Bränden ab manche sind von der Fläche so
groß wie New York oder Berlin überall in
der Provinz bedrohen die Feuer auch
wichtige Bahnlinien und Infrastruktur
die Einsatzkräfte von der schierengröße
überfordert allein hier im Bezirk Januar
kämpfen sie seit gut zwei Wochen gegen
15 Brände die außer Kontrolle geraten
sind wieder Einwohner helfen mit und es
bleibt die noch nicht viel anderes übrig
aber es ist eine Sisyphusarbeit denn
selbst wenn die Flammen gelöscht sind
brennend Torf und Wurzeln bis zu einem
Meter unter der Erde weiter Monate
manchmal Jahre lang wo ich jetzt du
kannst dann einen Punkt kommen wo du
keine Glut und keinen Rauch mehr siehst
und zwei Tage später bricht das Feuer
dann plötzlich wieder durch
mehr als 25000 Menschen mussten
zwischenzeitlich evakuiert werden und
für den Norden der Provinz wurden heute
weitere Evakuierungen angeordnet
viele haben alles verloren
kaum Schnee und Regen in winter und
Frühling und jetzt noch eine anhaltende
Hitzewelle die Menschen bereiten sich
auf die schlimmste Waldbrandsaison aller
Zeiten vor
denn die hat gerade erst begonnen
und in Kroatien kämpfen nach heftigen
Regenfällen einige Regionen mit starken
Überschwemmungen besonders betroffen ist
die Gegend östlich der Stadt Zadar in
manchen Ortschaften mussten sich die
Menschen in die oberen Stockwerke
zurückziehen oder ihre Häuser komplett
verlassen der Strom ist vielerorts
ausgefallen auch für die kommenden Tage
ist teils heftiger Regen vorhergesagt
kommen wir jetzt zum Sport zur Eishockey
WM Norbert und Deutschland hat ja auch
sein drittes Spiel verloren ja und
wieder nur ganz knapp und wieder hätte
das dab-team den Sieg durchaus verdient
am Ende aber ein zwei zu drei gegen die
USA Deutschland muss jetzt das nächste
Spiel gegen Dänemark unbedingt gewinnen
um die Chance auf das selbst gesteckte
mindest Ziel Viertelfinale zu waren
das deutsche Team gegen den
Tabellenführer auch im Pech Kai Wissmann
fällt den Puk ab zur US-Führung
Bundestrainer Kreis sieht seine
Schützlinge mindestens gleichwertig der
Ausgleich dennoch überraschend in
Unterzahl sensoramis im nachstochern die
USA unaufmerksam Justin schützt sogar
zur Führung 4 Sekunden vor Ende des
Mittels 2:1 doch es reicht wieder nicht
zwei Treffer der Nordamerikaner im
Schloss Drittel das letzte in Überzahl
besiegeln die dritte Niederlage im
dritten WM-Spiel bitte
positives wir haben zum dritten Mal
gegen eine Top Nation gespielt und
mindestens auf Augenhöhe auch die
mitgeresten Fans erkennen ist an das
deutsche Team ist besser als es der
Punktestand von 0 vermuten lässt
zum Tennisturnier in Rom da ist der
Weltranglisten erste Carlos in der
dritten Runde überraschend ausgeschieden
dagegen hat Jannik hanfman seinen
Siegeszug fortgesetzt und steht erstmals
in seiner Karriere bei einem ATP Masters
im Achtelfinale
so gut stand er noch nie da auf Platz 85
der Weltrangliste klettert Hansmann
mindestens durch seinen Dreisatz Sieg
gegen Marco checkinator aus Italien der
31-Jährige aus Karlsruhe hier oben im
Bild spielt weite Teile des Matches
souverän und kommt mit seinem zweiten
Matchball zum 6:44 Uhr 6 und 63
im Achtelfinale trifft er nun auf den
Russen André rubljof oder Alejandro
Davidovic fokina aus Spanien
[Applaus]
die Baskets Bonn haben gestern Abend in
Malaga das Champions League Finale
gewonnen das Team bezwang Jerusalem mit
77 zu 70 herausragend Spielmacher TJ
Shorts mit 29 Punkten der erste
Titelgewinn für die Bonner in ihrer
Vereinsgeschichte und der erste deutsche
Champions League Erfolg im Basketball
überhaupt
wobei man wissen muss in basketball ist
die Champions League 1 unter der Europa
League Fußball interessant danke nein
Danke
noch jemanden der ganz besonders unter
Druck steht dr Josef Dieter ist Forscher
und lebt seit 76 Tagen nicht auf sondern
vor den Inseln der Florida Kies zehn
Meter tief unter dem Meeresspiegel weil
erproben will wie der Körper den Druck
verarbeitet und ob die Menschheit
irgendwann ganz generell unter Wasser
leben könnte einen neuen Rekord hat er
schon jetzt aufgestellt bleiben will
aber 100 Tage bis dahin gibt's immerhin
leckere Schnittchen und sogar frisch
gekochten Kaffee
Dauerregen an den Alpen sonst
wechselhaft und ziemlich kühl ob sich
daran bis zum Feiertag was ändert das
erfahren Sie gleich von Katja horneffer
das heute journal sendet heute mit
Christian Sievers direkt aus der Türkei
um 21 Uhr auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend östlich von uns sieht das
Steve Benedikt weiter nach Norden es
brachte heute kräftige Schauer mit zum
Teil auch einzelne Gewitter und dann
kommt ihr ein Regenband von Nordwesten
heran so ein bisschen schmaler wird aber
in der Nacht doch Regen bringen zwischen
dem Emsland und dem Oberrhein sonst
gibt's nur noch wenige Regenschauer und
zum Teil ist es im Osten auch klar an
der Donau bildet sich Nebel die
Temperaturen sind nur auf 10 Grad am
Oberrhein und bis vier Grad an der Mosel
oder auch am alten Rand und morgen ist
es frisch für Mitte Mai im Westen liegen
die Höchstwerte nur bei 12 bis 16 Grad
an der Elbe aber auch hier in der Donau
oder Richtung München sind immerhin 17
bis 90 Grad und das Regenband der Nacht
zieht im Laufe des Vormittags weiter
nach Südosten sonst ist es recht
freundlich an der Nordseeküste
entwickeln sich Regenschauer am
Nachmittag setzt dann ergiebiger
Dauerregen am Alpenrand ein sonst was
ganz freundlich bei einem Wind aus
nördlichen bis westlichen Richtung am
Mittwoch erinnert sich an diesem Wetter
am alpenr and noch nicht so viel da
bleibt es beim Dauerregen Christi
Himmelfahrt der Feiertag wird sehr
sonnig und schon ein bisschen milder
guten Abend